[Music]
normally new leaders get this in the
first few days relishing the pomp and
pageantry found in their opening
meetings with foreign leaders Boris
Johnson has taken 29 days after becoming
prime minister to leave British shores a
reflection of the fact that this Prime
Minister is doing foreign policy like
none of his predecessors in modern times
at first glance in tone at least Angela
Merkel appeared to promise to listen to
ways to make the backstop the insurance
policy to avoid a hard border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic
surplus to requirement perhaps even
within a month the backs of has always
been a fallback position if one is able
to solve this conundrum if one finds
this solution we say we said we will
probably find it there the next two
years to come but we can also maybe find
it in the next 30 days to come it was an
offer of help it was not however a
promise to take it out of the withdrawal
agreement which Boris Johnson has
committed to back home prompted the
immediate question what ideas might he
have up his sleeve Forrest Johnson
Angela Merkel has just asked you whether
you're going to put forward specific
plans to solve the Northern Ireland
question are you and can you spell it
out for us now yes obviously we will we
do think that there are alternative
arrangements that could readily be used
to address the problem of frictionless
trader than organize a border and you'll
have heard them before whether it's
trusted trader schemes or electronic
pre-clearing all that type of solution
and more besides is what we will be are
wanting to discuss porous Johnson made
clear that no part of his plan would
involve putting up a hard border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic but
Angela Merkel was unable to give the
same commitment saying all sides are
still looking for solutions there were
smiles jokes but nobody was pretending
this was easy intentions did surface at
times we seek a deal and I believe that
we can get one we can do it your shop
and us I think is that is the phrase but
clearly
that was Boris Johnson saying we can do
it a phrase with unfortunate
connotations as was clear from her face
Chancellor Merkel was criticized for
using the remark at the height of the
migrant crisis standing in front of
these flags Angela Merkel sounded as
helpful as he's possible without
deviating from the Europe's hardline
addressing dear Boris she even made it
sound like she'd be prepared to
negotiate but both sides know there is a
long way to go before real progress is
made the Bundestag the Parliament here
in Berlin is pretty united against mr.
Johnson getting his way just as
opponents back in Westminster have been
joining forces today and the problem for
Boris Johnson is that even if Angela
Merkel alone wanted to help the rest of
the EU couldn't be more clear in their
resistance meaning the conversations
sometimes feels like it's going round in
circles I don't think that this
agreement is going to be reopened
because 27 EU members are against it so
is Angela Merkel and she said so today
and in previous days Boris Johnson could
be forgiven for thinking some of the
protests which dug him at home had
followed him to Berlin and the criticism
will undoubtedly follow him to Paris
tomorrow in the eve of his arrival
president McCrone was denouncing mr.
Johnson on brexit saying no deal would
be Britain's fault this could be about
to get trickier